so Sam welcome to St Louis it's actually
your first event in Grand chur if I'm
not mistaken it's the first time you are
taken part in s St Louis rapid and Blitz
uh are you looking forward to this event
yeah definitely I'm very excited to
debut in the grand Chester it's B Tour
I've been watching since I was a kid and
I'm very excited to be part of it uh
this one is a very exciting event
actually I was thinking what was the
first ever GCT event you have watched
and um which which one is the most
memorable for you um I mean I've been
watching since the singfield cups began
I think in 2013 exactly and probably the
most memorable one is definitely the one
where probably started 7
and0 I'm not sure that was a GCT event
but it was a singfield cup yeah it was
singfield C and let's say the seven out
of seven I mean did make huge impression
on you how old were you I was probably
12 or 13 at the time it was pretty
incredible to see someone at the top be
able to beat so many high level players
in a row game after a game so so that's
probably the one most memorable one yeah
actually you were here just not long
time ago and you won 9lx tournament I
mean congratulations on this Victory and
I was wondering um do you feel more
confident after you know winning this
event especially now that you will play
with many players from that one uh yeah
thank you I mean it was definitely a big
achievement for me winning this
tournament and it definitely gives
confidence to you know be able to win a
tournament with so many elite players I
think I have game confidence and and
playing better against them yeah just a
few days ago you actually took part in a
grand Swiss event in I of men and um I I
was wondering how do you assess the your
participation there and of course
everybody saw the game you where you bat
L fuja was nice game and so how can you
assess your participation there uh I
overall it was good and I had some
serious chances of getting the top two
spots and I had like two really tough
losses in both scenarios so uh it was
kind of a sour taste at the end but
overall I think yeah I had some good
wins one of them FIA it was decent
tournament overall and do you think you
will try to get the Revenge right now
are looking forward to play against him
in this tournament yeah uh I mean
playing him I me he's very good at fast
chest speed chess so it'll be exciting
to play him in a different format as
well whom else are you looking forward
to play against in this event and S
Louis R I think I've played most of the
players in this field but probably nple
the least so that would be a very
interesting
matchup uh how do you actually deal with
those fears you know playing against uh
you know higher rated players top rated
players in the world you know how do you
deal with that yeah well I mean the fear
was definitely a long time ago when it
was probably 14 15 I think just playing
them over and over again helps you get
over the fear and at this point it's
just I'm just playing and with healthy
respect but I know I can definitely beat
them yeah you were one of the students
of this program from casparo chess
foundation for young talents uh what
impact on your chess it had and um how
how did it feel actually to work with
Gary casparo himself uh I do think the
Casper chash had a huge impact on me I
was 101 when I joined it and just
analyzing with Gary was really helpful
for me I always tried to you know get
into his brain try to see how he thinks
about the game and I think that was like
a 3 four year period which really helped
me a lot yeah uh that's great and what
actually my last question is what are
your shortterm goals and long-term goals
you I know that you're professional
chess player so how is it to be the
one uh shortterm goals I mean well we
just had two very serious tournaments
the US championship and Grand Swiss so
there's nothing uh as serious as that in
the short term but I'm just looking to
do well in this tournament I think it's
a fun tournament a good opportunity yeah
but let's say what what what do you
think you can reach uh which levels uh
in the Chess World let's say maybe 2,800
do you think is one the goals of course
yeah I definitely have the the highest
goals possible I mean that's why I
started playing chess when I was six 5
years old and I still have that goal
today do you enjoy playing chess and
starting yeah yeah I enjoy playing chess
maybe not so much uh some years ago but
now that it's only chess I mean it's all
I
do I definitely enjoy playing that's
great all the best of luck for you s
thank you